today I want to talk to you about the
three different conditions that cause a
monopoly to exist
I'm Patrick may be your host of value
tame and weekly and today we're going to
talk about a different kind of monopoly
than the one we're accustomed to I'm not
talking about our buddy
name uncle Pennybags who we play the
game and we roll the dice and you hope
to land on boardwalk and you know past
go and collect $200 and not go to jail
and we're not talking about that game
today we're talk about real life
Monopoly three things cause a monopoly
to happen one only one firm sells the
product there's only one firm that sells
the product to two there is a very
difficult barrier of entry meaning the
government's created so many regulations
and licensing for you to get in that it
makes it tougher for smaller business to
go in and compete with the bigger
business if there's too many regulations
too many laws very difficult for the
smaller business to compete with the
bigger business three is there's no
closed substitute so close substitute
could be I have a choice between behind
a car but there's motorcycles if a car
sold for a hundred thousand dollars then
there's a motorcycle then there's a
bicycle I have a close substitute so
when you think about those three things
I'll give you a few examples
business-wise when Apple first came out
with our iPhone you remember when the
iPhone first came out it was a big hit
it's called a smart phone it's
incredible it does your thinking for you
one of the best things that happen for
you and I his Droid came out right and
one the best thing that's recently
happened for everybody including iPhone
users and the consumer is Samsung came
out with a new phone called Galaxy s5
that phone is gonna influence Apple to
get a bigger screen and get better if
they don't they're gonna lose a lot of
customers to Samsung and they need to be
a little bit more affordable for the
average middle-income family to be able
to buy that if they don't they're going
to lose customers you think about
Netflix product rule it did very well
stocks to an incredibly wall Amazon
decides they want to compete with
Netflix you know what that's gonna do if
you own Netflix be excited about this
because the products going to get better
they're gonna have to deliver a better
product for you because there's a car
petition now there's somebody that wants
to take that marketplace if Netflix is
that whatever percentage Amazon's just
gonna lower it and Netflix need to think
about creative ways to prevent that from
happening some people may say well
Groupon was a monopoly when it first
came out yes but it doesn't last long
because within one year
couple thousand group buying websites
came out that gave him so much
competition that made Groupon changed
their regulations with their
relationship with businesses where they
had to go from 50/50 profits to sixty
forty to seventy thirty to 80/20 because
there were other people that were doing
the same and that continues on happening
and happening and happening because the
number one thing that prevents a
monopoly from happening is choice when
there are choices everybody has the
pressure to improve I don't want to go
to Starbucks I have coffee bean if I
don't want to go to Burger King I have
McDonald's if I don't want to go to
Subway I have Quiznos the list goes on
because choices prevents monopolies from
taking place so when you think about the
pendulum if we have a pendulum here on
one side there's only one company it's a
pure monopoly on the other side we have
pure competition many many firms what do
you think is the best opportunity for
you and I what a lot of firms so that's
what we call it free trade when there's
you know allowing Japan to come and
compete against Ford and Chevrolet when
Toyota comes here Honda comes here it's
allowing international companies to
compete domestically that not only
creates the products to get cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper for you or not but
it also makes the competitors produce
better products innovation gets better
because they're seeing their competitors
what they're doing this has happened
firsthand to me with competitors that I
have that we deal with because every one
of us is forced to improve collectively
representing that one industry together
but above all if there's one
organization that can both prevent and
influence a monopoly from taking places
the US government here's why a US
government can get involved in and say
no this is a monopoly this is not going
to be taking place and on the opposite
side US government can also create a lot
of regulations by the way you and I vote
because it may seem like we're doing the
right thing
let's over regulate this industry and
this business because I don't like Apple
I don't like Walmart I don't like this
let's create more regulations you know
what the bigger businesses say no
problem you're helping us out you know
why the more deregulation the less the
smaller business can compete with the
top guy which means what for you and I
prices don't go lower and what you and I
vote for as the consumer is to make
things better efficient and more
cost-effective the more the regulations
that less that's gonna happen for us so
my message of the week to you and please
be sure to subscribe to the channel and
comment cuz I'd love to hear from you
things that can cause a monopoly is that
what it is you see action of a good
today I want to talk to you about three
different condition conditions today I
want to talk to you about the three
different conditions that cause a Mahna
Mahna Polly what was a thinking about
Myrna Polly like what even sounds like
mono/poly monopod
it sounds like a city in France you know
I went to a city in France called mana
Poli